with one of the biggest reality shows on
television the porn stars crew has
struck pawnshop pay dirt two more times
and even bacon count but not every deal
they make on the show is a perfect play
and when they get ripped off they get
ripped off big time here are the worst
moments when the porn stars got
seriously cheated Shoeless Joe Jackson
fake in the season 6 episode say it
ain't so
Rick shelled out $13,000 on a book he
believed might contain the authentic
signature of baseball greatest Shoeless
Joe Jackson Rick akin have been more
excited during the appraisal you know
how rare it is to find his signature no
no it's the rarest sports signature
period but despite the sellers
questionable certificate of authenticity
and Rick's own reservations of all the
sports signatures in the world this is
the one most faked he took a gamble and
bought it anyway after shelling out the
cash Rebecca his book expert told him
that the signature was likely a fake so
record and sent it out to another
Authenticator who reiterated the bad
news not only was there forgery it was a
laughably bad one so much for that
homerun Rick Willie Mays strikeout in a
2012 episode Corey made the blunder of
forking over $31,000 for what he
believed was a game one Willie Mays San
Francisco Giants uniform from 1961 but
the red flags of this one were apparent
from the jump for starters the uniform
was pristine which Chumlee noticed right
away this doesn't look game worn Willie
Mays was a badass he was sliding around
the dirt and the grass I imagine there
will be a bunch of stains on it
good observation chump also the seller
had no authentication paperwork
whatsoever which is never a good sign so
big Hoss took a gamble and boy we'll see
all kinds of wrong not only did golden
silver pawn failed to retail it at a
ridiculous asking price of 80,000
dollars but they only ended up getting
only 19,000 $200 for it at auction
around two years later a nearly $12,000
loss and it gets worse halls of shame
reported that the uniform was never worn
in a game by mace because it never even
belonged to mace that technically means
Corey didn't get his ripped off as he
could have but we seriously doubt
is happy with how that deal went down
schools in session schools Wells Fargo
heist in FF sees an episode called
Cory's big play Rekha made the unusual
mistake of buying something he was
unsure of a nineteenth-century Wells
Fargo strongbox containing an old prison
ball and chain and unsure is putting it
lightly
okay so what are you trying to say fake
he still drops four hundred and fifty
dollars on the box only to have his
hopes of a profit shot down by expert
and show regular mark the beard of
knowledge halt pattern this is a
complete fantasy piece it's a complete
thing damn it Rick leave it up to the
old man to rub it in auction losses if
the world famous Gold & Silver Pawn Shop
can't we tell an item they always have
the option of sending it to auction
that's what Rick tried to do with
several big ticket items including a
1940's Indian motorcycle with a sidecar
and a Vic flick owned and played Fender
Stratocaster which he put on the block
at Julien's Auctions in Los Angeles
unfortunately he took a hit for $29,000
on the motorcycle and a $35,000 on the
guitar
ouch he must not have done well with his
other items either because he reported
his total loss at around $100,000 that's
almost an atom I'm getting my ass handed
to me ah it doesn't feel good lime cited
by the bio when the History Channel
launched Cajun porn stars in 2012 the
boys from Las Vegas apparently felt
blindsided by the move according to TMZ
the network of the promised no spin offs
would be produced The History Channel
called the new edition a southern spin
on the original and they weren't kidding
I got them Gator I got the record which
one we got a good neither the network
nor the Harrisons commented publicly on
the tension but former porn stars
manager Wayne Jeffries said he was the
mole that talked to TMZ and he said he
got fired for it looks like in this case
porn stars didn't get ripped off by a
customer they got ripped off by their
own network you've endured thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love soon
you